réfugiés vietnamiens le gouvernement
propre français propose d'en accueillir
immédiatement 5000 m messieurs bonsoir
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
vietnamiens candidats à l'émigration
c'est un responsable de hanoi
l'ambassadeur du vietnam auprès de l'onu
à genève qu'il a lui-même annoncé
c'est vous dire que le problème que nous
connaissons actuellement est que vous
avez vécu intensément hier soir ne fait
que commencer
d'autant que l'ambassadeur a précisé que
son pays ne s'opposerait pas au départ
de ses habitants c'est vous dire aussi
si l'on va vers de nouveaux drames
des centaines de milliers d'hommes de
femmes et d'enfants de papillons en
quelque sorte qui gêneront se cogner aux
vitres de l'indifférence des pays
voisins
les malaisiens puisque nous parlons des
voisins les malaisiens viennent d'avoir
une idée il propose de regrouper tous
s'y réfugier aux états unis d'un à
centre qui devrait pouvoir accueillir
quelques trois cent mille personnes
la france à son échelle veut jouer la
solidarité tous partis politiques
confondus à l'exception du pc qui ce
matin dans l'humanité dénoncent là je
cite pierre juquin l'exploitation d'un
drame tous partis politiques confondus
donc toutes classes sociales toutes les
organisations petites et grandes veulent
faire quelque chose au plus haut niveau
deux initiatives aujourd'hui la décision
d'accueil de 5000 réfugiés indochinois
décision prise en conseil des ministres
nous allons en reparler
et puis quelques heures après la
réception chez le présent république des
animateurs d'un bateau pour le vietnam
parmi lesquels je vous pouvez
reconnaître rémois rond claudine roy
yale andré glucksmann ce que nous voyons
ici soutenir ce jean paul sartre qui a
semblé fatigué gens pensent alors
ressenti ensuite dans une conférence de
presse au collège de france a résumé cet
entretien avec le chef de l'état mort d
un pont aérien
permettant de ramener le temps vous
réfugiez le plus grand qu'on pourrait
une terre d'accueil en france un lieu
chez peugeot liés pour être être libre
soit 1 quand je crie la solution la plus
défavorable soit sous la forme par
exemple d'un réfugié pour 1000 personnes
une une adoption chez des personnes
privées de ces réfugiés surtout des
enfants
bien sûr le président je vous l'aï dit
nous a sérieusement fait goûter
il est content parler de ce que lui
avons dit à tokyo où il se rend
maintenant pour parler de tout ça avec
les autres gouvernements mais il l'a que
peu d'espoirs de convaincre les
gouvernements d'europe d'être plus
accueillant il pense que la france a
fait beaucoup et qu'elle ne peut pas
pour l'instant faire davantage sur ce
point n'a pas été complètement formel il
essaie peut-être une chance je ne seront
pas en tout cas c'est dans l'ensemble
une fin de non recevoir non pas positive
ni négative riz n'a rien dit qui
permettent d'espérer une solution il est
vrai que le président n'a pas donné une
réponse formelle dans un sens ou dans un
autre
aux demandes du groupe il est vrai qu'il
n'a pas formellement
hormis promis qu'une seule chose c'est
que tous les réfugiés qui seraient dans
son bateau battant le drapeau français
serait acceptée en france
et là-dessus il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un
doute non d'autant plus que c'est un
principe fondamental
nous avons tous chacun dans notre style
insisté sur la nécessité d'un nact
exemplaires ou spectaculaires et qui
pourrait transformer dans une certaine
mesure l atmosphère dgo
ce qui est normal dans les rencontres
entre les hommes d'état et je ne dirais
pas du tout que sa réaction finalement a
été négative